حزب الله الحجاز همم
كمنظمه
صعب جدا ان الواحد يجزم ب- ااا تفاصيلها
يعني مثلا اذا قرن بالحركه الشيرازيه
الحركه الشيرازيه منظمه الثوره الاسلاميه
في الجزيره العربيه الا بعدين تحولت لحركه
الاصلاح قالتها معروفين كوادرها معروفين
خطاب
منشوراتها اللي كانت في همم الثمانينات
معروفه
يعني حتى لما رجعوا الى المملكه بالعفو
همم اللي صدر في التسعينات كان واضح همم
مجموعه حزب الله الحجاز همم اذا نبدا من
البدايه فكره خط الامام اساسا خط الامام
اللي خط الا هو الجماعه والامام نسبه الى
همم قائد الثوره الايرانيه همم
رحمه الله الخميني همم اذا جينا همم هذا
الخط في البدايه كان متعاطف مع افكار
الخميني
وكثير منهم لا يرجع الفقير يعني هذه من
المعلومات الكثير من الناس اللي خارج
دائره الشيعيه لا يعلمونها
بكثير من مقلدين خارج ايران بل حتى داخل
ايران لم يكن اكثر تقليدا يعني ايه الله
شريعه مداري
او حتى زعيم العلميه في النجف السيد ابو
القاسم اخوي كان عنده مخالدين اكثر همم
تماما خط الامام واصبح له رابطه فقهيه
كبيره مع المرشد الايراني الجديد ليش لان
الشباب اللي في الخليج وفي الدول العربيه
اللي فيها نسب شيعيه اللي ولدته في نهايه
السبعينات جيلي همم
لما الخمائي طرح مرجعيته في سنه 94 وهم
شباب في نهايه سن المراهقه وبدايه 20
ايضاق همم
تبنوا مرجعته فاصبح ارتباطهم فقهي وليس
فقط تعاطفي ااه
حزب الله الحجاز ظهرت مع احداث الحج 1407
77 14
الصدام
الباحثين ان تاسس في ما يوصل 87 ااه احداث
الحاج حصلت تقريبا في يوليو نهايه شهر
يوليو 31 يوليو يعني تتكلم عن ثلاثه شهور
بدايه التاسيس كان فقط بيان تاسيس من دون
اي همم
بعدها ثلاث شهور حضرت احداث الحج طلع بيان
اللي يتوعد الى حد اخر بيان صدر في
العام الحالي
ما في اي اسماء لا يوقع باي اسماء
ابرز الاسماء اللي مذكوره عندي في البحث
همم عبد الكريم بن ناصر الشيخ عبد الكريم
الناصر شخصيه ما حد يعرف عنها الا اسمها
يعني ليس عالم دين معروف ليس خطيبا مفوحا
ليس كاتبا همم لا يملك همم
سمعه سواء سلبيه او ايجابي